(lively music)
- Musical spaces are gendered.
The history of choral
singing is that women sing
in high voices, and men
sing in their lower voices,
and for an individual for
whom that model does not fit,
choir is not really a space for them.
I'm really trying to
create a new tradition
and create spaces for trans
and non-binary singers.
- [Announcer] This Great
Big Story was made possible
by Proctor & Gamble.
(choral singing)
I'm William Sauerland, and
I'm the artistic director
of the Oakland Gay Men's Chorus.
I'm trying to make a new model
for what a men's chorus can look like.
We've performed at the professional level
in big concert halls in
front of two thousand people,
all the way down to small church venues
with maybe 50 or 60 audience members.
The chorus is made up of
gay men, bi men, trans men,
non-binary individuals,
straight men, cisgender women.
Everyone is allowed to
have a place at the table.
Let's do that again; let's
do that the whole page.
(choral singing)
(piano playing)
I wouldn't characterize having
trans or non-binary singers
in a chorus as a challenge.
If you have a trans
singer who's going through
a vocal change, it might
mean allowing them to move
the vocal parts as their voice deepens
or changes in some way.
I want anybody who feels like
their voice has been silenced
to make their voice even louder.
(choral singing)
(sewing machine whirring)
(light singing)
- I have always loved singing.
I sang with the symphony, but
I was in the alto section,
and I really wanted to be
in the section behind me.
They got to wear tuxes.
I had to wear a dress.
When I decided to transition,
I found that there were
places that didn't want me.
I felt like I had to
apologize for who I was.
When I joined the
chorus, I had been afraid
because I thought my
voice stood out too much.
It's like it's not masculine enough.
I felt so self-conscious
'cause my voice is different;
it's different from theirs.
I want my voice to be like theirs,
but, you know, that's a hard journey.
♪ Some days ♪
♪ It seems like ♪
♪ Love's in short supply ♪
Once I got in there and
started making friends,
I felt like I had walked into
a family of so many brothers.
I'd take my kid, Al, to rehearsals,
and Al had a whole bunch of uncles.
♪ So starting ♪
Suddenly, I was in a place where
I could start just being me
and they let me be comfortable.
- Ready, and a...
(choral singing)
- In one of the shows,
I got to sing the solo.
When I was done, Billy blew me a kiss,
and in that moment, I knew my
voice as David was accepted.
It was OK for me to be me.
(choral singing)
(bright music)
- We are not taking any
step back by having trans
and non-binary singers.
Our sound has not suffered.
In fact, it's the opposite.
We actually sound better
because of these singers.
Our community and our sense
of family is even stronger
because we have said in an outward way
that you are all welcome,
and music is the thing
that brings us together.
(lively music)